the jurogan experience saying you know
hinckley just got out of jail he's doing
shows hillary's the goat well he's he's
doing shows but the first venue that had
him in brooklyn they cancelled because
they were getting so many death threats
i had tickets who old people
i i would see hinckley he's a good
musician
his his songs are pretty solid wait what
yeah pull him up all right pull him off
he had a lot of time yeah yeah a lot of
time to work no nobody's good at singing
it's solid yeah it's like singer
songwriter type stuff nothing about
manson no no no marilyn no manson has
good stuff here we go here we go really
here we go let's get let's get some
let's get some johnny
you're doing great
he looks like far from uh
the song is called the places i have
been
and it's available on spotify i've been
in jail for four years
the shower
the mess hall on the streaming side so
check him out all right don't no lead up
yes here we go get to it
all right dude let me hear what you've
got cut to it
he's still on spotify
[Music]
fine
bob dylan yeah he's got a lot of bob
dylan's influence
he's got 60s
[Music]
you can drug test his eyes
yeah dude i guess that mk ultra
do you think that's what they did
what is that do you think he was like
one of the manchester union candidates
that song sucks you know that's always
[ __ ] crazy
maybe this is a better one can we get
along he's got a song called can't we
get along oh please
play it
hello everybody
yeah yeah yeah
shout out to jody foster what up
joey i'm still here for you i don't
believe in lesbians
everybody's fighting
here and now this is terrible
yeah
this is much better play the best
charleston
they reported my
[Music]
we
tickets
can't we get along
all day long
it starts with me and you that's like
john caparulo yes no a little bit
got the jambs though for real tell you
this is solid this is good folk now that
you know tankly it's funny
yeah it's not good and he's gonna get
laid there's a woman who's into every
kind of guy 100 and he's gonna get laid
the kind of guy who has the balls to
shoot at reagan yeah and he hit a [ __ ]
and hit him i'd [ __ ] him and outlive
them and i'll love them
yeah what was that what was it how many
years did you get 41. 41.
okay look at your game girl look at your
game girl
i hate your garbage man
well you know the whole story behind
madison manson actually thought he was
gonna get a recording deal with brian
wilson of the yeah
they like they became tight i believe
it's brian wilson yeah
there was like he knew
music producers they think it had
something to do i forgot the details it
had something to do with like one of the
murders like he was threatening people
they were like hey man i know it's
pre-cancer culture but you can't be
murdering a bunch of people this is not
bad this is not that bad no let me hear
more
living in that confusion
frustration
three three million
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's good this is good 60's music it's
not bad it's very simple listen to the
whole album it's great i recommend it
okay that's right now that's a wrap
that's not that good either when you
hear about the the mk ultra [ __ ] it's
wild
i don't know enough about it no i
haven't you got to read chaos by tom
o'neill he's actually fitzsimmons is uh
greg fitzsimmons's uh next-door neighbor
for like 20 [ __ ] years it's a crazy
story fitzimaz is the one who told me
about the guy he said hey i got this
neighbor he's been working on this
charles manson book for 20 [ __ ] years
it's been his obsession it's ruined his
life he he lost he like had to give
money back to publishers because he
didn't finish the book because he he
developed so much material because he
got into it from the perspective of like
it was an anniversary thing the
anniversary of the murders and he was
writing this book it's called chaos i
can't recommend it enough it's a [ __ ]
fantastic book and so as he's writing
the book he uh realizes like oh my god
the whole story it was originally an
article and they turned into a book but
he's like the whole story of manson's
wrong so what's really about is the cia
giving lsd to hippies and he was one of
the guys they experimented with it was
all part of the mk ultra experiments
100
there was some [ __ ] involved
because he kept getting out of jail easy
and the the the sheriffs would all say
the same thing we was above my pay grade
they had to let him out so he'd get he
would like he was involved in murders he
was involved in robbery all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] they let him out of jail and
they were just giving him an acid
they not only did they give him acid
they taught him how to use acid to
manipulate people and convince them to
commit murders wow yeah the cia trained
charles manson i think allegedly maybe
not maybe somebody who was a rogue agent
the cia this is not official government
policy they would never allow this
they're gonna get you somebody did it
they took that out no we're going to
keep that in because uh the book is
amazing i think it's the old cia i think
the cia back then in the 60s
during that mk ultra period there were
different wow joe how about whitey
bulger oh yeah bro that's both yeah
though that's fbi no no no
really he was mk ultra what does that
mean he didn't have a deal with him he
was in alcatraz and they were like
hey this is for schizophrenia we're
testing this drug this is gonna it will
lessen your time if you do that oh i
didn't know that
oh my god juror who helped convict crime
boss whitey bulger feels guilty after
learning he was in mk ultra holy [ __ ]
whitey bulger wrote to a juror who
convinced him that he would be dosed
with lsd monitored by a physician and
repeatedly asked leading questions like
would you ever kill anyone no over 50
times know who else what ted kaczynski
what
mark kazunski was a part of the lsd
studies at harvard
they tortured him they did all kinds of
wild [ __ ] to him and [ __ ] with his
head and he was an already broken man
yeah there's a great documentary on uh
netflix about him about ruby rose and
all that yeah well the kozinski one is
it's all about the unabomber but it's
like how [ __ ] up his childhood was he
had some kind of weird disease when he
was a baby and so they put him in this
hospital where they didn't touch him at
all for months wow what that's nazi she
didn't touch him they didn't touch him
at all because he had this this the
parents weren't allowed to visit him
oh i thought that was exactly
his development no no they experimented
on him later with lsd but this was just
the fact that he was just sick and they
took him to this hospital to take care
of him and when they did they didn't
allow his parents to visit him and no
one handled him so when he was a little
[ __ ] baby no one was taking care of
them all the emotional attachment to
people they literally created a
sociopath yeah
well because his brother is the one who
turned him in his brother's a normal guy
you